[Música]
para mí
muchas gracias
cuando yo empecé el camino para intentar
dedicarme al cine a ser directora y
guionista lo que yo pensaba que
necesitaba lograr era tener una buena
idea
bueno una gran idea bueno una super idea
bueno una mega hiper extra ultra archi
buenísima idea de la [ __ ]
no había conseguido descifrar el secreto
para conseguir ser director de cine
ahora bien
qué es una mega hiper extra ultra archi
buenísima idea de la [ __ ]
para mí es la fia de mi niña atrapado en
el tiempo el apartamento pulp fiction
el gran dictador annie hall todas esas
ideas increíbles que me habían hecho
querer dedicarme al cine y además amarlo
así que con eso en la cabeza me puse
manos a la obra
a escribir mi mega hiper extra ultra
archivo ni sima idea de la [ __ ]
y qué es lo que pasó y qué es lo que
pasó yo voy a enseñar lo que pasó
y eso pasó un folio en blanco
un frío o repitan te terrorífico y a
cromático folio en blanco
y por qué porque ese folio blanco pues
por una amiga mía que se llama
inseguridad
la inseguridad es un hija de [ __ ]
porque me hacía pensar que ninguna de
mis ideas merecía vamos a deponer entra
una chica ya días veo que has poco voy a
entrar una chica
todo me parecía malísimo nada estaba a
la altura de todas esas mega hiper extra
ultra archi buenísimas ideas de la
[ __ ] que me habían hecho a mí intentar
dedicarme al cine todo me pareció
horrible nada llegaba a la altura de lo
que habían creado esos super artistas
increíbles a los que yo admiraba y claro
eso me produjo una depresión creativa y
una crisis existencial enorme y una
adicción a la pizza gigante que todavía
no he podido controlar pero bueno no
pasa nada pero un día viendo youtube y
comiendo pizza
vi una entrevista de stephen king
bueno total total que estaba comiendo
pizza y viendo una entrevista de stephen
king
y de repente empezó a contar cómo había
sido el proceso creativo de su primera
novela era un lozano y pobre
veinteañeros
y de repente se le ocurrió la mega hiper
extra ultra archi buenísima idea de la
[ __ ] que es carril
al parecer se le ocurrió la idea
escribió tres páginas y las tiró
porque le parecieron una [ __ ] una
[ __ ] una caca de vaca lo tiró a la
basura y dijo pero qué hago yo qué hago
intentando escribir si yo soy un pobre
chaval que es profesor de universidad y
no vale para nada
y ahí se quedó esa mega hiper extra
ultra archi buenísima idea de la [ __ ]
que es carry y ahí se habría quedado si
no fuese suerte de él porque su mujer se
lo encontró un día bueno lo mejor al día
siguiente porque si no que pasa que no
limpiar en esa casa y vaya paseando
[Música]
y tú qué es lo abrió
lo leyó una chica tiene la regla cada
carta a todo el mundo con yo y le dijo a
su marido
ptv
esto es una mega hiper extra ultra
buenísima idea de la voz
y así estuve
se puso a escribir
su primera novela carrie que luego la
publicaron y fue un exitazo increíble
que lanzó su carrera y además es
gracioso porque la idea que él había
lanzado a la basura terminó lanzando su
carrera y a mí al ver la entrevista me
entró una duda existencial
que un tío que yo admiro que me parece
un creador increíble al que se le
ocurren ideas mega hiper extra ultra
archi buenísimas de la [ __ ]
tiene inseguridad
como yo
y es que la inseguridad nos hace pensar
que nuestras ideas no son buenas que son
una caca de vaca xxi merece estar en la
basura la inseguridad nos hace pensar
que nosotros no somos tan buenos como la
gente a la que admiramos por ejemplo
a mediados del siglo pasado un chico
adolescente vive en liverpool su nombre
es john lennon john lennon quería ser
músico y quería ser músico porque estaba
chiflado por un artista que se llamaba
elvis
lennon quería ser como elvis y su madre
que era una tía maja le compró una
guitarra y ayudó a aprender a tocar la
guitarra entonces en una de estas
lecciones el adolescente
y dándolo todo intentando aprender a
tocar la guitarra lo elvis la loly la
luna de repente se agobio y dijo ya está
se acabó no no no voy a seguir
intentando o sea es que no se me da
fatal es que soy malísimo nunca voy a
ser como elvis presley entonces su madre
se levantó estaba en una silla invisible
se acercó a john lennon
y le dijo abed hijo mío es verdad no vas
a ser el bis pero vas a hacer
john lennon y su hijo adolescente del
liverpool contexto
y madres
porque contestó así john lennon
por inseguridad porque en la cabeza de
un chaval de liverpool en los años 50 no
podía entrar que algún día decide john
lennon significaría lo mismo más o menos
que decir
elvis presley imposible o sea se le
explota la cabeza porque cuando nosotros
escuchamos la frase
no vas a ser el bis pero yo chicos vamos
a ser john lennon nosotros escuchamos
john lennon
pero ese adolescente del liverpool lo
que escuchaba
no vas a hacer elvis vas a hacer el
pringado de lyon
claro es que eso es lo que hace la
inseguridad y yo me di cuenta que lo que
tenía que hacer para conseguir ser
artista y seguir adelante y rellenar ese
folio en blanco no era tener una mega y
pérez travolta archi buenísima idea de
la [ __ ] no era creer en mis ideas
he preguntado antes a la gente del
público si había alguien que estuviese
intentando dedicarse a una carrera
artística y hay unos cuantos de vosotros
que queréis ser artistas y los tenemos
aquí delante
les he preguntado quiénes eran sus
artistas favoritos estos artistas
increíbles que les hacían querer
dedicarse a esta profesión que han
elegido y cuáles son nuestros artistas
favoritos enseñarnos lo a ver que que
tenemos tenemos calatrava nolan tim
burton os al cine y arquitectura
maravilloso muy bien chicos pues yo os
voy a dar la clave si no lo habéis
incluido ya para que podáis seguir
nuestros sueños podéis sentaros muchas
gracias porque yo me he enterado que
además entre el equipo del tedh hay una
chica que quiere ser directora de cine y
me gustaría que se hubiese aquí a la
silla a charlar conmigo se llama nun
hamayel por favor un aplauso enorme para
ella
[Aplausos]
siéntate tienes una idea buenísima ya
está pillada vale nur
levántate
puedes sentarte a nur también le
preguntado que me dijese algún artista
de los muchos que le inspiran y me dijo
que era roberto rossellini
uno de ellos dice roberto rossellini va
a ser un nombre que va a pulular en su
cabeza y la va atormentar lo mismo que
le hace disfrutar con sus películas le
hace sufrir con no poder hacerlas nunca
vas a ser roberto rossellini no vas a
ser roberto no vas a ser ni su hija
isabella rossellini
y tú lo que tienes que hacer es luchar
luchar contra esa voz migración a los
ojos ya los ojos
concéntrate imagínate a ti misma
escribiendo un guión en roma
no
eres una farsante y no tienes buenas
ideas no vales para nada
nunca vas a ser roberto rossellini
puedes abrir los ojos esa preciosa voz
aterciopelada que he escuchado
es tu inseguridad y lo que tienes que
hacer con tu inseguridad es decirle que
la calle
no tiene micro a ver qué tal lo hace
dilo
dilo con fuerza nun por dios
y grita melón por dios ponte de pie
perfecta una plaza por favor para
siéntate nación
vale hace es genial porque cada vez que
tú vayas a hacer algo creativo cada vez
que te enfrentes a un rodaje a un folio
en blanco a cualquier situación creativa
esa voz se va a atormentar la tiene
tiene la voz pues lo que te juro de
verdad no la escucha me tiene que decir
la voz cállate cállate y además te digo
una cosa muy importante tú
no eres roberto rosa directo eres nur
jamal y esa tía es una mega hiper extra
ultra archivo misiva directora del arte
gracias
[Aplausos]